it's a special day for star wars fans
you guessed it cheryl
say it with me okay
maybe
the fourth
the fourth
be
with you we're both delaying you did it
we did it i mean we got there uh and
lucky for us some new star wars content
has arrived premiering on disney plus
may 27th obi-wan kenobi just dropped a
new trailer and it's been so difficult
for me to wait all day and not actually
watch it before this so join me in
taking a look
i want every lowlife and bounty hunter
to squeeze him
[Music]
you can't escape him
all right
cheryl i don't know how much you have to
say about this but i gotta
i got a lot
i got a lot i'm pretty excited i would
just like to give this entire minute to
you because i feel like i'm gonna get
educated and and i would tell me your
feelings so so here's the thing you know
star wars fans pay attention to all the
small details because there's a lot of
lore there are a lot of characters there
are a lot of stories and side stories
that aren't part of um
of the movies that we see and even like
the disney plus series that we've seen
so far there are video games and comic
books and novels and history that are in
all of those that people are seeing
actually come to life
in uh in this trailer even from the
cartoons thing that you've you've seen
in um rebels and whatnot that are
happening in this trailer so it's very
exciting for people that have been
following along that are big fans of the
broader star wars stories um
and just just the opportunity to see
those things that they've loved for
years come to life in a series like this
i think it's very very very cool i'm
very excited and of course darth vader's
coming along i was going to say the same
thing just for the record i was going to
say the same thing exactly what you just
said there yeah i know i knew you were i
knew you were which is why i didn't want
to like echo i didn't want you know
i wanted to go first because i didn't
want to echo everything you you were
going to say
so
i love you for that